foreign
in this situation Mike's grab my hand
and do a very logical thing I step in
and punch Mike in the middle of the face
again it's a really simple idea and you
see this constantly Nike to formed the
whole form is not the idea the idea of
these simple things they just don't work
out for me so my initial idea is simple
I want to hit Mike and knock them off of
me just doesn't work it's too strong as
I do this you notice I step my back foot
in between his feet trying to take his
bounce and knock him to a bad angle but
it doesn't work it's real stable right
after I hit Mike's going to be coming
back towards me right like this because
he's coming in to get me and as he comes
in to get me I lower myself here which
means he'll hit my hips now notice
there's no strain on my back he's
writing right across my hips which means
all this force is going into my legs and
none of it's coming into my back
see that one more time is feet
hey